foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
once again can I please ask you to take
your seats this is a very important
moment for the parliament
good afternoon
we are here today in the dark shadow
cast by Putin's War
a war we did not provoke
a war we did not start
an outrageous invasion of a sovereign
independent state
on behalf of the European Parliament I
condemn the Russian military aggression
against Ukraine and the strongest
possible terms and express my solidarity
with all those suffering and all those
skilled
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
the message
the message from Europe is clear
we will
stand up
we will not look away when those
fighting in the streets for our values
face down Putin's massive war machine
we will support the international
Criminal Court's Jurisdiction and
investigation of war crimes in Ukraine
we will hold him accountable just as we
will hold lukashenko
we are facing an existential threat to
the Europe we know
the Europe
so many have given so much for
and this is why on this important day
I am pleased to announce that President
zelenski will address US shortly
followed by Speaker Ruslan Stefan the
chair of the radar of Ukraine and allow
me also
to have a special welcome to the
ambassador of Ukraine and the Ukrainian
people present in the plenary today
thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Mr President
thank you for showing the world's what
it means to stand up
thank you for reminding us about the
dangers
of complacency
everyday acts of extraordinary heroism
by ukrainians inspire us all Defense
Forces and citizens making the ultimate
sacrifice to delay a column of Tanks
senior citizens standing up to face down
Russian troops with nothing but pride
and sunflowers as their weapon
Brave women forced to give birth in
Metro stations next to their
kalashnikovs
follow the world that our way of life
it is worth a cost
all those who remember living under
occupation will attest to that all those
standing up in Belarus all those looking
to us in Moldova in Georgia it is worth
it for us
for the Next Generation
for all those in Ukraine and around the
world who believe in Europe and in our
way and for all those who want to be
free
our European response was on this play
over the last very painful days
this must be our whatever it takes
moments
neighboring states have accepted
hundreds of thousands of fleeing
ukrainians
Europeans sheltered ukrainians in their
homes
we have implemented a series of
unprecedented massive sanctions
we have gone further and will provide
much needed weapons to Ukraine we have
declared that Russian aircraft and
oligarchs private jets are no longer
welcome in our open Skies we have moved
for Russia to be disconnected from the
Swift system
[Applause]
we have banned we have banned Kremlin
propaganda tools European citizens
organizations businesses Sports have
taken a clear and forceful stand
underlining that they will not deal with
or welcome an aggressor and Europe
stands ready to go further still
we recognize Europe's
Ukraine's European perspective
and as our resolution clearly states we
welcome Mr President Ukraine's
application for candidate status and we
will work towards that goal because we
will
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
because we will and we must face the
future together
Mr President we stand with you in your
fight for survival in this dark moment
in our history when you look to this
European Parliament you will always find
an ally a space to address Europe and
the world and always always a friend
this European Parliament has a long
proud history of being a thorn in the
side of autocrats and in this spirit I
will seek a ban on any representatives
of the Kremlin from entering European
Parliament presences because aggressors
[Applause]
because
aggressors
and warmongers have no place in the
house of democracy
Dear Presidents dear members let me
finish out by stealth setting out four
important principles for our future
first of all
Europe can no longer remain reliant on
Kremlin gas
we need to redouble our efforts
[Music]
to diversify our Energy Systems towards
a Europe that is no longer at the behest
of autocrats that will put our energy
Security on stronger footing secondly
Europe can no longer welcome Kremlin
cash and pretend that there are no
strings attached
Putin's oligarchs and those who bankroll
him should no longer be able to use
their purchasing power to hide behind a
veneer of respectability in our cities
in our communities or in our sports
clubs
their super Yachts should find no Harbor
in our Europe and we can no longer
and we can no longer sell passports to
Putin's friends allowing them
to circumvent our security
no more thirdly investment in our
defense must match our rhetoric Europe
must move to have a real security and
defense Union
[Applause]
[Music]
we have shown last week that it is
possible and desirable and more than
anything it is necessary
and fourthly we must fight the kremlin's
disinformation campaign and I call on
social media and Tech conglomerates to
take the responsibility seriously and to
understand that there is no being
neutral between the fire and the fire
brigade
[Applause]
[Music]
president Michelle president Wonder lion
High representative Burrell thank you
for ensuring European unity and
commitment in facing the threat I know
that all of us all the members of this
house will take the United message of
Europe back to our constituencies
president zelenski thank you we are
together now we will be together in the
future because we are with Ukraine thank
you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you very much
dear
present in the media in in this session
Hall you know
over the last couple of days I don't
know how to welcome and greet everybody
because I cannot say good morning
or can say good afternoon or good
evening
and I cannot
and that's true
because every day for some people this
day is not good
for some people this day is the last one
I speak today now about my citizen
citizens of Ukraine who are defending
by paying the ultimate price
they defending freedom
I'm very happy
that what I've seen here now and heard
here now I'm very glad
to sense this mood
the uniting unifying mood I'm happy that
we have unified today all of you all the
countries of the European Union but I
did not know but this is that this is
the price they will have to pay and it's
a tragedy for uh for me to tragedy for
every Ukrainian tragedy for our estate I
mean this Pro this high price very high
price thousands of people who were
killed two revolutions one war
spent five days of full scale invasion
of the Russian Federation
you know
I am
I'm not I don't read off the paper off
the [ __ ]
because the paper phase in this in the
life of my country has ended
now we're dealing with reality we're
dealing with killed people real life you
know
and you know
I believe that
we today
we're giving lives for values for rights
for freedom for the desire to be equal
as much as you are
we are giving away our best people the
strongest ones the most value-based ones
ukrainians are incredible
and very often we love to say
that will win over everyone
and I'm very happy
that you are not only talking about it
but you can see that
and we indeed we will overcome everyone
and I'm sure I'm convinced
there is an expression
Ukrainian
Choice your European choice of Ukraine
that's we're striving for and that's
what we're going to and we went to
so I would like to hear that from you to
us
we could hear
um the the that the Ukrainian choice for
Europe from you I have
some time up here because we have breaks
between the missile strikes and
bombardments and this morning was a very
tragic one for us
two cruise missiles hit hurricane
the city which is located to the borders
of the Russian Federation there were
always many Russians there and they're
always friendly there were warm
relations there more than 20
universities are there it's the city
that has the largest number of
universities in our country
the youth is bright smart there
the people who gathered there all the
time and was gathering there all the
time for celebrating Allah celebrations
at on the largest Square in our country
the Freedom Square and
and this is the largest Square in Europe
and that's true this is called the
Freedom Square can you imagine this
morning two cruise missiles
hit this Freedom Square dozens of killed
ones this is the price of freedom
we're fighting
just for our land
and for our freedom
despite the fact that all life cities of
our country are now blocked
nobody
is going to enter and intervene with our
freedom and Country and believe you me
every square of today no matter what
it's called it's going to be called as
today Freedom Square in every city of
our country
nobody is going to break us we're strong
we're ukrainians
we have a desire to see our children
alive I think it's a fair one yesterday
16 children were killed
again and again President Putin is going
to say that is some kind of operation
and we are hitting a military
infrastructure where our children what
kind of military Factories do they work
at what tanks are they going with or
launching cruise missiles he killed 16
people just yesterday
foreign
people are very much motivated very much
so we are fighting
for our rights for our freedoms
for life for our life and now we're
boring for we're fighting for survival
and this is the highest of our
motivation
but we are fighting
also to be equal members
of Europe
I believe that today
we
are showing everybody that's exactly
what we are the European Union is going
to be much stronger with that so that's
for sure
Without You Ukraine
is going to be lonely lonesome
we have proven our strengths we have
proven that as at a minimum
we are exactly what's the same as you
are so do prove that you are with us do
prove
that you will not let us go
do prove that you indeed are Europeans
and then
life will win over death and light will
win over
Darkness glory be to Ukraine
thank you
thank you
foreign
thank you very much for your strength
message strong message president for
your bravery and for your conviction I
will now give the floor to the speaker
of the Ukraine Parliament Ruslan Stefan
took for his intervention
foreign
first of all I would like to thank you
for the possibility to speak to address
the European Parliament and I would like
to say look at my back you see the
shoots that every everybody sees today
the whole world says today
eight years ago Ukrainian people
said categorically no to the Russian
aggression to their attempt
to change their way to home to European
nation to the United European Union
to
to a very successful unifying process
that they demonstrated during all these
years
instead our right to develop our right
to be a democratic state that chooses
itself its own way
was completely ruined by the country
that doesn't respect international law
international principles
that destroys territorial integrity and
sovereignty and the result you see today
very clearly
amount of
killed amount of wounded
you know that the aggressor
attacked hurricane full scale tonight
today
other other cities are being constantly
under attack
you know I think
that
in the history of Europe there is a
Crossroads
Europe
is now fighting
aggressor
and
it is very important how this challenge
will be rebuffed by the United
civilization
dear
dear
parliamentaries I know that you will
look at a very whole range of serious
economic sanctions that you will adopt
against the aggressor I would like you
to understand that today Ukraine is
defending the border of the Civilized
world
and God forbid Ukraine Falls nobody
knows where Russian aggressor will stop
thank you
I
you know when when I was in my official
shoot and we were working in the
Parliament and we have been taken very
important reformists laws but just today
I was four times descending into the
basement because
above my one and a half thousand Old
City there are bones missiles and they
do everything to break Ukrainian Spirit
but this wouldn't happen
so think
now what can happen to Europe
if if the Russian horrible Empire is
renewed if the European Union would be
able to protect the space of freedom
which was created during the last tens
dozens of years and what is felt in
Eastern European countries now when
Russian tanks will confront their
borders
the to which other regions Kremlin will
look after it conquers Ukraine that I
would like to call upon you to think
strategically to support the unity of
European Union to support Ukraine to
make its strategic partner and the most
important act don't be silent collect
all your efforts and show that Europe
today is Unified as never because the
threat today is like never before and we
best support
to the people of Ukraine in this Darkest
Hours will be the real recognition of
our European aspiration because the
membership in the European Union even
before
these events that started
on the 24th of February was supported by
the majority of europeanians and this is
our mandate this is our mandate to have
relationship with you with European
Union because the Ukrainian people have
done have made their choice and I'm
calling upon the older member states and
the leadership of European Union to
support the candidate the aspirant
status for Ukraine which is Now
supported by the whole of Euro Ukraine's
you know that Vladimir zielinsky has
already signed the letter uh with
our application to membership according
to article 49 of European Union
agreement dear friends in the project of
the resolution of the European
Parliament there is a whole range of
sanctions going to be reflected against
the aggressor I would I call upon you to
support them because
let's together
[Music]
we have but to confirm to confirm the
Churchill expression about that there
are no small people and no small
countries let's
we know that Ukraine has proven that
this slogan during the last six days
let's be
let's be worthy of those people who are
perishing right now for the European
Union for the future of our European
house
let's understand that there cannot be
peace in Europe without Ukraine
that there could not be integral Europe
without Ukraine
glory to Ukraine thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you very much Mr speaker thank you
for your words for your courage and for
your commitment
to peace and parliamentary democracy I
give the floor now to the president of
the European Council Sean Michelle for
his statement
[Music]
foreign
Parliament president of the commission
members of the European Parliament
dear
president of Ukraine Vladimir zielinski
dear speaker of the Ukrainian Parliament
thank you
the words
that you have expressed
Pierce our hearts and our souls and show
how serious
the situation is
the challenge is a very serious one and
the decisions that we're going to have
to take together are also very serious
ones because once again blood and War
have reached European soil Vladimir
Putin
Putin and then provoked War based on the
speechable lies and he did it
only for one reason
because you dear friend
in Maiden
who made the choice of Freedom democracy
and full of flow
and their chalice
it's not only you train that's under
attack
international law
rules-based International order
democracy human dignity are also under
attack disease
geopolitical terrorism pure and simple
[Applause]
we must support Ukraine and you are we
are supporting to train we must protect
peace we must put a democracy and
international law
and ladies and gentlemen
out in the Atlantic Alliance is strange
United
perfectly coordinated and we are also
working closely with the members of the
G7 and with the United Nations and more
and more countries are engaged in an
anti-war tradition along with people
from around the world with one common
message one common message Russia stop
the rule go home let's torch
[Music]
[Applause]
we are putting maximum pressure on
Russia and its leaders we are stepping
up to support Ukraine and the Ukrainian
people I salute with all of you poison
zelinski and the brief people of Ukraine
for their courage and composure and it's
also our duty to rise to this historic
moment
ladies and gentlemen
we promised together that we would react
quickly that the consequences for Russia
would be massive and severe and our
actions have matched our words we have
responded with massive and unprecedented
sanctions we imposed sanctions on
political and military leaders on
oligarchs on Vladimir Putin on Saturday
lavrov we are also taking powerful
measures to severely restrict the
of the foreign currency reserve of the
Washington Central Bank we are excluding
key Russian Banks from the Swift system
and we are also imposing severe
sanctions on these sectors of Russia's
economy
many times they miss you
ladies and gentlemen
we have to be honest about all of this
these sanctions
will also impose a cost on us and this
is a price worth paying because what's
at stake is our values our convictions
and our common future
[Applause]
hello
colleagues
obviously supporting Ukraine is
mobilizing Financial Resources that's
what we're doing and we're going to
continue to do there's going to be an
international donors conference we also
together with our member states be
committed and engaged on the direct
borders with ingrown with the Ukraine
will be
helping refugees people fleeing war and
conflict and we'll be showing our
solidarity to the Ukrainian people and
those who are mobilizing
but obviously solidarity
is also demonstrated via defensive
military resources which are being and
will be delivered
on
this was something that we decided on
Saturday morning together with the high
representative for foreign affairs
we decided to activate the peace
facility with the support of member
states so that we can
support the purchase of these defensive
military
this defensive military equipment which
is so crucial for the Ukrainian people
Now ladies and gentlemen a few moments
ago president zielinski looked Us in the
eyes he opened up his heart and he has
made an announcement which we've now
received officially
the request for the European Union to
officially recognize that Ukraine as a
candidate country
it'll be up to us as a European Union to
act in accordance with the times it's
going to be difficult we know there are
different views in Europe there are
various views on this subject and it'll
be up to the European commission to
produce an opinion on the basis of which
the council will take its
responsibilities on board the council
will have to seriously look at the some
symbolic political and legitimate
requests that's been made
and we'll have to make the appropriate
choices in a determined and clear-headed
manner
ladies and gentlemen
when this war was launched
Vladimir Putin thought that he would
break European Unity he was wrong
he probably thought that he would face
inertia
paralysis the search for excuses to
avoid taking decisions but he was wrong
when he launched this action he probably
thought that he would take Ukraine
easily and rapidly but he was wrong
because the Ukrainian people are
resisting bravely
he probably thought
that he would
launch a fatal blow against that which
we incarnate freedom and the rule of law
but again he's wrong
and in 1961 General
de Gaulle said that every Retreat
excites the aggressor it makes him
redouble his pressure and makes his
action easier
Western powers can best serve World
Peace by standing up
firmly against aggression that's the
position of President zielinski and
that's the position that we have to
adopt we have to stand firm
and look
at the aggressor and we have to see
President zielinski as the Incarnation
of stability security Enlightenment and
European values thank you
thank you thank you very much president
Michelle I now give the floor to the
high representative of the union for
foreign affairs and security policy
Joseph
for his statement
president
of the Europe
yeah dear members of the European
Parliament
I will try to share with you my thoughts
on the meaning of the tragic events that
we are living
and the provisional lessons that we can
draw from them
especially for the common security and
defense policy
which I have the honor to try to develop
and it remains
an intergovernmental policy
a policy which is
yet in the hands of the member state
it cannot be implemented efficiently
without the strong cooperation of the
commission competencies
I think this is the
the moment in which
the geopolitical YouTube is being born
this is the act of the birth of a
geopolitical Europe
once we are aware of the challenges that
we Face the moment Europe must assume
its responsibilities the moment we
become fully aware that for the first
moment since the second world war we are
seeing one country invade another this
is a country with nuclear weapons this
is part of its intimidation tactics
it makes me sick when I think about the
historical analogies and how we can look
back at the events at the start of the
second world war of tragedy
to which Europe is being confronted
today
to return a tragedy
far from frightening us
should Galvanize us
first we got it believes the idea that
the European project had lost its
momentum because the Horizon of the war
has been faded
unfortunately not
this reminds us that the evil the
tragedy and the war Never Fade Away
and it's about the relationship with
Rome with the user's force with the
violence who have been debating here we
have been debating for years
to find out can you can counter it and
this is why in the recent years we have
talked more about defense issues that in
the past and we have begun to set up
joint military programs that's why the
European Parliament itself has voted to
set this European Defense fund and the
member states has created this European
peace facilities and now we are
mobilizing in order to provide arms to
Ukraine
European Council
in the next weeks we'll adopt the
Strategic compass
and with the invasion of Ukraine by
Russia we must amplify our reflection
adjust our means and anticipate our
responses
because one of the lessons that we had
to learn from the invasion of Ukraine is
that more than ever Europe must to think
strategically about itself its
environment and the world
this is no longer a luxury it's a
necessity
Euro must amplify his reflection on
security issues and European Parliament
has had an important role to play in
this regard
we think we need to think about the
instrument of coercion
retaliation and counter-attack
in the face of Reckless adversaries
because all we need to understand is
that to make peace we need to be too
but to make war is enough to be one
this is exactly what Mr Putin is telling
us
and that's why we have to increase our
deterrent capacity a lot
we need to increase our deterrence
capacity in order to prevent War
and it's
and it's clear
but our deterrent has not been strong
enough
to stop Mr putting aggression
but since this decoration has started we
have reacted in the last few days in a
way that Mr Putin didn't expect
and we are showing him that we will
never sacrifice our freedom
and the freedom of others on the altar
of our well-being and prosperity
being president of this parliament in
2007
I had the opportunity to tell to Mr
Putin I twice
on the aftermath of the killing of a
journalist Anna parietuskaya I told him
we are not going to change human rights
by urugus and this is the moment to
repeat and to act on that we will not
share
we will not
we will not abandon the defense of our
human rights and freedom because we are
more or less dependent on Russia and we
have to start working quickly as the
commission has proposed in order to
cancel this dependency
last Saturday
after having hold another foreign First
Council
and attending the debate of the European
Union Council I was talking with you
president Michelle and you told me
are we doing everything we can
is there something more than we can do
is that enough
are we so so powerless and you told me
saying do act we have to push member
states in order to adopt decision on
shift and to take Russia out of the
financial system
think about how can we arm
Ukraine not country by country one after
all in an incoordinated Manner and you
encouraged me to talk with member states
again in few hours we agreed on using
this European peace facility in order to
bring financial support and coordinate
member stage on arming Ukrainian Army
and people in less than 24 hours another
taboo had fallen
and the president of the commission
immediately showing a strong leadership
start working rather to get an agreement
with our International Partners in order
to make possible to switch off Russia
from the financial system and you know
what now
half of the reserves of the Central Bank
of Russia are completely out of their
control they are frozen do you imagine
this is the coercion capacity
three days ago it was impossible and now
it's possible and they start feeling the
consequences in terms of inflation and
the fall of their currency
yes we have capacities
we have mobilized these capacities
and we have to continue doing so
putting together the capacities of the
member states
and European Union I want to remember
you that the European peace facility is
not part of the budget that you vote
is another budget it's an instrumental
fund managed by the member states
because we claim that we European Union
with a peaceful force and we cannot
provide arms to anyone else yes we can
yes we have done on the next budget
think about it
why don't you vote the next budget
Use Your budgetary Capacity you have the
budgetary capacity of this institution
to put the wage means in order to face
the next Crisis and the next Russian
aggression
we are also working
on the domain International Airport we
are working in the international Arena
to try and build a coalition to condemn
the uh to condemn Russia within the UN
they had no votes in favor and only
abstentions
there were countries traditionally
Allied to Russia that did not vote in
favor of them they abstain and so now we
need to build an International Coalition
so the next U.N General Assembly it will
be the entire world that will condemn
this aggressor nobody can look the other
way
there is no justification for a powerful
country attacking its weaker neighbor
you cannot speak of uh pacifism you
cannot have the aggressor and the
attacker on the same footing
we have to be by their side
we have used our coercive capacity
not necessarily using weapons when we
talk about Europe being a hard power
people think only in military power but
there are other ways to exert hard power
capacity
is a way of influencing another's
behavior and this is not just done by
weapons it has been done by the European
commission and extraordinarily a
successful uh measures as put in place
by the commission so thank you president
Rhonda lion
we're not talking about mobilizing
missiles but these sanctions can have a
hugely important effect on a country
they will not allow Russia to spend the
money that we have spent on their gas to
fund this war
that is ladies and gentlemen I believe
the most important lesson that we can
draw from these tragic circumstances
we cannot
simply call for the rule of law and hope
that our trading a commercial
relationships will help move everybody
towards a more democratic path
the forces of
evil the forces that want to use
physical violence as a way to resolve
conflict are still there and against
these types of forces we have to show a
much stronger capacity to act we need to
be more consistent we need to be more
united than we have been up to now
we have done a lot I think we have
surprised the world I think we have a
surprise Putin by our rapid capacity to
act and we must continue along this path
this moment here in Parliament with your
applause
that shows us that the EU institutions
must continue on this path that we have
started this is the moment that
Europeans understand they live in a
dangerous world
and in order to confront that we must
have a stronger Union the pandemic has
opened the door to Innovative actions it
has helped us move along the path to
Greater Unity when facing this virus and
now this tragic moment should give us
fresh impetus to be ever more united and
to counter these actions that threaten
human life security and the prosperity
of all thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much
thank you very much hi representative I
now give the floor to the president of
the European commissioner Ursula
vandelion for a statement
[Applause]
[Music]
Madam president of the European
Parliament Mr President of the council
High representative Mr president of the
Ukraine Dear volodomir Mr Speaker of the
Ukrainian Parliament
my honorable members
War has returned to Europe
almost 30 years after the Balkan Wars
and over half a century after Soviet
troops marched into Prague and Budapest
civil defense Sirens again went off in
the heart of a European capital
thousands of people fleeing from bumps
camped in underground stations holding
hands crying silently trying to cheer
each other up cars lined up towards
Ukrainian Western borders
and when many of them ran out of fuel
people picked up their children and
their backpacks and marched for tens of
kilometers towards our Union
they sought Refuge inside our borders
because their country wasn't safe any
longer
because inside Ukraine a gruesome death
count has begun men women children are
dying once again because a foreign
leader President Putin decided that
their country Ukraine has no right to
exist and we will never ever let that
happen and never ever accept that
[Applause]
honorable members this is a Moment of
Truth for Europe and let me quote the
editorial of one Ukrainian newspaper the
chief independent published just hours
before The Invasion began and I quote
this is not just about Ukraine it's a
clash of two worlds two polar set of
values
end of quote
they are so right
this is a clash between the rule of law
and the rule of the gun between
democracies and autocracies
between a rules-based order and a world
of naked aggression
how we respond today to what Russia is
doing will determine the future of the
International System
the destiny of Ukraine is at stake but
our own fate also lies in the balance we
must show the power that lies in our
democracies we must show the power of
people that choose their independent
past freely and democratically this is
our show of force
and today a union of almost half a
billion people has mobilized for Ukraine
the people of Europe are demonstrating
in front of Russian embassies all across
our Union
many of them have opened their homes to
Ukrainian fleeing from Putin's bombs
and let me thank especially Poland
Romania Slovakia and Hungary for
welcoming these women men and children
Europe will be there for them not only
in the first days but also in the weeks
and months to come that must be our
promise altogether
[Applause]
and this is why we are proposing to
activate the temporary protection
mechanism to provide them with a secure
status and access to schools medical
care and work they deserve it we need to
do that now
and we know this is only the beginning
more ukrainians will need our protection
and solidarity we are and we will be
there for them
our Union is showing a Unity of purpose
that makes me proud
at the speed of light
the European Union has adopted three
waves of heavy sanctions against
Russia's Financial system its high-tech
Industries and its corrupt Elite
and this is the largest sanctions
package in our Union's history
we do not take these measures lightly
but we feel we had to act these
sanctions will take a heavy toll on the
Russian economy and on the Kremlin
we are disconnecting key Russian Banks
from the Swift Network
we also banned the transaction of
Russia's Central Bank the single most
important financial institution in
Russia and this paralyzes billions of
foreign reserves turning off the tab on
Russia's and Putin's War we have to end
this financing of his work
[Applause]
and second
we target important sectors of the
Russian economy
we're making it impossible for Russia to
upgrade its oil refineries
prepare and modernize its air fleet and
to access many important Technologies it
needs to build a prosperous future we've
closed our skies to Russian aircraft
aircraft including the private jets of
oligarchs and make no mistake we will
freeze their other assets as well
fancy cars or luxury prosperities will
freeze that all together
and thirdly in another unprecedented
step
we're suspending the licenses of the
kremlin's propaganda machine the state
owned Russia Today and Sputnik and all
as their and all of their subsidiaries
will no longer be able to spread their
lives on to justify Putin's war and to
divide our Union and these unprecedented
actions by the European Union and our
partners in response of an unprecedented
aggression by Russia
each one of these steps has been closely
coordinated with our partners and allies
the United States the United Kingdom
Canada and Norway but also for example
Japan South Korea and Australia
all of these days you see that more than
30 countries representing well over half
of the world's economy have also
announced sanctions and Export controls
on Russia
and if putting was seeking to divide the
European Union to weaken NATO and to
break the International Community he has
achieved exactly the opposite we are
more united than ever and we will stand
up in this war that is for clear that we
will overcome and we will prevail we are
united and we stay United
[Applause]
honorable members
I am well aware that these sanctions
will come at a cost for our economy too
I know this
and I want to speak honestly to the
people of Europe
we have endured two years of pandemic
and we all wished that we could focus on
our economic and social recovery but I
believe
the people of Europe understand very
well that we must stand up against this
cruel aggression
yes protecting our Liberty comes at a
price but this is a defining moment and
this is the cost we are willing to pay
because freedom is priceless honorable
members this is our principle freedom is
priceless
[Applause]
our investments today
will make us more independent tomorrow
and I'm thinking first and foremost
about our energy security
we simply cannot rely so much on a
supplier that explicitly threatens us
and this is why we reached out to other
Global suppliers and they responded
Norway is stepping up in January we had
the Record Supply of LNG gas we're
building new LNG Terminals and working
on interconnectors
but in the long run
it is our switch to Renewables and
hydrogen that will make us truly
independent
we have to accelerate the green
transition because every kilowatt hour
of electricity Europe generates from
solar wind hydropower or biomass reduces
uses our dependency on Russian gas and
other energy sources this is a Strategic
investment
and my honorable members
[Applause]
because on top less dependency on
Russian gas and other fuel fossil fuel
sources also means less money for the
kremlin's war chest this is also a truth
we are resolute
Europe can rise up to the challenge
the same is true on defense European
security and defense has evolved more in
the last six days than in the last two
decades most member states have promised
deliveries of military equipment to
Ukraine Germany announced that it will
meet the two percent goal of NATO as
soon as possible
and our Union for the first time ever is
using the European budget to purchase
and deliver military equipment to a
country that is under attack
500 million euros for the European peace
facility to support Ukraine's defense
as a first batch we will now also match
this by at least 500 million euro from
the EU budget to deal with the
humanitarian consequences of this tragic
War both in the country and for the
refugees honorable members
this is a watershed moment for our Union
we cannot take our security and the
protection of people for granted we have
to stand up for it we have to invest in
it we have to carry our fair share of
the responsibility
and this crisis is changing Europe
but Russia has also reached a crossroad
the actions of the Kremlin are severely
damaging the long-term interests of
Russia and its people
more and more Russians understand this
as well
they are Marching for Peace and Freedom
and how does the Kremlin respond to this
by arresting thousands of them
But ultimately
the Longing For Peace and freason
Freedom cannot be silenced there is
another Russia besides Putin's tanks and
we extend our hand of friendship to this
other Russia be assured they have our
support
[Applause]
honorable members
in these days independent Ukraine
facing a Darkest Hour
at the same time the Ukrainian people
are holding up the torch of freedom for
all of us
they are showing immense courage
they are defending their lives
but they are also fighting for Universal
values
and they are willing to die for them
president zelensky and the Ukrainian
people are a true inspiration
and when we last spoke he told me again
about his people's dream to join our
Union
today the European Union and Ukraine are
already closer than ever before
there's still a long path ahead
we have to end this war and we should
talk about the next steps
but I am sure
nobody in this hemicircle can doubt
that the people that stands up so
bravely for our European values belongs
in our European family
and therefore honorable members
I say long live Europe
and Long Live a free and independent
Ukraine
Slava Ukrainian we're with you
glory be to Ukraine
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much President Van Der
Lyon we now move to the speakers on
behalf of the political group starting
with Manfred Weber for the Epp group
[Music]
s 160.
the 24th of February
significant date in Europe and the world
War has returned to Europe and of course
it seems what we're doing here it hardly
measures up to what the ukrainians are
now doing
so right now we're focusing on our
admiration for the ukrainians with their
president leading them their their
strength their love of Liberty
the decisiveness they are the heroes of
the European way of life the 24th of
February is a day of freedom for Europe
from Dublin to Athens from Lisbon to
Riga
and the same feeling of shock everywhere
dismay with this aggression at the at
the on the other hand an admiration for
the people of the Ukraine they're
fighting for us they're fighting for our
values these days this Kiev moment of
the 24th of February
makes everyone European this moment
forces us to give clear answers when
president zielinski asks us
are we welcome
may we become members of the EU do we
belong then I say on behalf of the
largest party of Europe yes you are
welcome yes you belong to the European
Union you are friends
this Kiev moment forces us to look at
the Alternatives Putin is the brutal
aggressor he represents the opposite of
our convictions for nationalism for
autocracy
this brutality of trying to have
Imperial influences the opposite of us
that we want to conquer borders come and
have demonstrate respect to everyone and
defend our democracy and defend our
freedoms this key moment also means we
have to be honest
we have to make it clear that we have to
take action with these sanctions we have
an exemplary package I'd like to thank
everyone for the last day's work
we as a group we support these measures
but one thing is very clear a few days
ago a week ago we didn't really hear the
same words some people were refusing to
talk about North stream to as a possible
sanction we weren't decisive enough
so today that means we have to take
action and we have to really abolish
this unanimity in foreign policy this
key moment also means a strong NATO but
it also means a strong European pillar
and the Epp visited NATO troops in
Lithuanian and I asked the commander
what's your greatest wish and we say 50
of our time is to deal with the
technical differences among uh for
example the the radios and the equipment
what we need is a European structure
that's what they were asking for us
those people who are now defending
Europe this key moment means we have to
think big as Europe so this conference
on the future of Europe has to be
rethought we've concluded our citizens
dialogue now it's the right time to make
this conference a genuine place to
decide about the future of Europe to
have the courage together and if we
don't do it now when are we going to do
it and this Keith moment demonstrates to
us that
we have to really look at the policies
we're deciding energy policy as Mrs
Funderland just said we have to speed
the energy transition up we have to have
new trade Partners New agreements on
energy our keys moment means for us that
we are together bound to the U.S
with Joe Biden we have to use this
moment
it demonstrates how important it is to
have
uh how decisive our trade partners are
for free freedom and democracy we have
to have a new free trade agreement with
the US to demonstrate this it's the
right time this key moment to look at
the future development of Europe where a
new age is Dawning
we need endurance but the European way
of life is worth it Freedom has no price
price of freedom is something you pay
when you lose it and the ukrainians are
demonstrating that today and we stand
with you Ukraine
thank you president Weber I now give the
floor on behalf of the snd group to
erase Garcia Perez
gracias president thank you president
Putin's war against Ukraine marks the
beginning of a new stage in Europe and
in the world
these are historic times and we need
historic decisions
financial and Military Support to
Ukraine de connecting the main Russian
Banks from the Swift platform the
activation of the international
protection directive to assist Ukrainian
refugees and banning the kremlin's media
machine
are all part of a qualitative leap in
our capacity to respond
Western democracies have achieved an
admirable Unity to face this Challenge
and it's crucial that we maintain our
Unity given the serious challenges that
we will continue to have to face the
four sanctions packages headed by Mr
Burrell are the first step in a long
crisis that will raise new dilemmas
for example how to continue to support
Ukraine
or how can we react to probable Russian
reprisals
Unity requires courage and sacrifice
it's only with courage and sacrifice
that we can achieve the energy
Independence that we need to defeat
Putin
are utter
commitment to a global energy order
that's based on renewable energies over
the long term needs to be complemented
complemented with the creation of
strategic reserves of gas for the short
term we also need carried courage and
sacrifice to welcome all the refugees
who are fleeing War we need shared
responsibility there the Cowardly attack
of Putin shows his real fear which is
democracy a successful democratic
transition in Ukraine needs to serve as
an inspiration to those who bravely have
taken to the streets in Russia the fight
for Peace and Freedom of the Russian and
Ukrainian peoples require our support we
cannot rest until Putin as judged as a
war criminal by the international
criminal court
Putin's attack
will also reveal his accomplices from
the extreme European right and a model
of living together which of Life which
represses the oppositions
censors the media and denies individual
rights currently in the cities and towns
of Ukraine it's not only their security
and territorial integrity that's at
stake but the world in which we want to
live it can be a democratic world based
on international law diplomacy and human
rights or it can be a different world
based on Brute Force spheres of
influence and violations of rights that
should be Universal
no tyrant
will make us renounce our desire to
forge alliances that are based on peace
which protects the sovereignty of
Nations progress freedom and the
Integrity of our borders
history is never wrong
we can't leave ukrainians alone as the
Spanish
felt during the first half of the 20th
century in the fight between Fascism and
democracy the resistance of the heroic
Ukrainian people will be the Triumph of
Western democracies and let me just
conclude with a personal comment
I'm proud of Europe the Europe of today
the Europe that does not resign itself
to what's going on Europe that looks
back to learn from history but above all
looks forward to defend what we hold
most precious democracy and peace thank
you
[Music]
Stephanie
thank you very much Madam president Mr
President
High representative
and let me start by welcoming the
courage of the Ukrainian men and women
who are fighting not just for their
country but their right to choose their
own destiny president zielinski and the
president of the Ukrainian Parliament
you are heroes of democracy
the European Parliament today has shown
it as a strong Ally of the Ukrainian
people
Europe is a shield that protects its
democracy and freedoms for all the
peoples of Europe of all the decisions
taken this week
let me just say you have the absolute
support of our political group
there is huge work that has been done by
the European institutions in order to
put in place and make operational these
sanctions and support measures for
Ukraine
alone or divided I can't even imagine
what Putin would have done to our
continent you have been up to this
historic challenge
let me go even further when it comes to
support measures for Ukraine
I believe giving the candidate status to
Ukraine is important now of course it
will take some time for the Ukraine to
join the EU there'll be a rigorous
process but I think it's important that
we acknowledge that the ukrainians are
fighting for democracy they are already
part of our community I think the status
of candidate country would be a fair
acknowledgment for this
foreign
sections to really
dry up all of the financial resources
for Putin in this war technological
embargoes gas oil
against the oligarchs as well and end to
the golden passports and residence
rights as you have mentioned Madam
president all of these sanctions must be
activated as soon as possible
we
I hope uh that this will not hit the
Russian people too hard as we know who
are majoritarily opposed to this what we
need to work on the Russian opposition
here in this homicycle as well now these
measures will have a cost for our
economies so we need to mutualize costs
anti-european level for the countries
and companies who are hardest hit by
this let me conclude with one final
point at Mr President Madam president to
say that there is still some work to be
done for Europe to guarantee its
solidarity is shown by this crisis our
journey towards strategic economy needs
to include a review of the defense
budget at National and European levels
as well as an energy autonomy strategy
as well colleagues
the protection of our European model
comes at a cost my political group
believes that our freedoms are a
fundamental value we are willing to
assume that cost when it comes to
sanctions or investment in tools of
European sovereignty
we understand sacrifices of the European
people and also the sacrifices of
millions of Europeans before us who have
made this the freest continent in the
world thank you very much very much I
now give the floor on behalf of the
green group to Philip Lambert's
Iranian friends
we do not have enough words to praise
your courage and determination to defend
your freedom
your resistance is a wake-up call to all
Democrats around the world
without the will to fight
democracy will perish
to your aggressor I say
your lies for justifying War cannot and
will not remain unchallenged no Mr Putin
Ukraine is not ruled by Nazis on the
country it's legitimately elected
president stems from a family who has
blooded in the Holocaust
no Mr Putin there's no genocide going on
in the donbass what is happening there
is a war that you yourself started eight
years ago which took already 14 000
Cliffs and that your Invasion brings
only to a new level
no Mr Putin
Ukraine has never intend
[Music]
Telly does it inherited in 1991 from the
Soviet Union in exchange for its
territorial Integrity we should have
been trampling on ever since you you
annexed Premiere in 2014 no Mr Putin
there was no perspective for Ukraine to
join nato in the foreseeable future and
if there is such an aspiration in
Ukraine as there was in so many nations
once subjugated by the Soviet Union your
aggression against Ukraine explains why
no Mr Putin the NATO member states have
no intention to deny the Russian
people's rights to peace and security it
is your Reckless actions that Imperial
those legitimate aspirations
the reality Mr Putin is that the people
of Ukraine chose for freedom for
democracy for rule of law for peace
and that choice made by a people so
close to Russia's by history and
geography was never a threat to Russia's
security but to the very existence of
your authoritarian and kleptocratic Rule
this is the real reason for the invasion
and the cost of precious human lives and
livelihoods both Ukrainian and Russian
the reality Mr Putin is that your brutal
aggression against a Ukrainian people is
doomed to fail
you wanted to deny their very existence
as a people your aggression in cementing
the unity against the invader
as citizens of the European
crane
and against the foreign state it is a
direct challenge to the values that lie
at the foundation of our Union
ever since it was started the European
project was and remains a peace project
so that the rule of brute force be
replaced by the rule of law
so that democracy dialogue compromise
and cooperation across National borders
provide the best basis for shared and
sustainable prosperity
we Europeans cannot stand by Idol when a
partner country is invaded and when all
fundamental values are challenged in
such a brutal way
this is why short of direct military
Intervention which would be foolish we
must and we will provide the Ukrainian
people with all the support we can in
order to face the aggression
this is why we must and we will provide
Safe Haven without
any
discrimination to all those who are
fleeing the war to seek refuge on our
territory
this is why we must and we will mobilize
all political economic and financial
means that all disposal to exert maximal
pressure on Putin's Russia in order to
make him stop his aggression
and let me be clear to the people of
Russia we have no quarrel with you you
too have the right to live in dignity
and many of you are standing up daily to
defend it at Great personal risk
we know that resuming the Diplomatic
dialogue with your country is the only
path to a sustainable peace on our
continent but this can only happen if
the aggression stops
as far as Europeans meeting the
challenge put To Us by Putin's war will
test our strength or determination and
above all or Unity
it will not come cheap
therefore it will force us to make hard
choices the first must be for cohesion
within and across member states
the global financial crisis the Eurozone
crisis and the pandemic have deepened
social and economic Injustice in our
Union
it cannot be that once again the brunt
of the massive efforts required to
counter putins for will be carried by
the weakest shoulders
that be the case the legitimate
resentment would sub the very basis of
our social contract as well as though
for your of our Union
and this would fulfill one of Putin's
unset goals dividing us
the second must be for energy in
Independence indeed or massive
dependence on Russia for raw materials
and energy is a primary reason for
Europe's lack of determination to deter
the Russian regime up until now no
surprise when forty percent of our gas
30 percent of our call overall end of
our nuclear fuels don't forget that is
provided by Russia sdu is almost devoid
of these resources his whole plan really
to replace this massive dependents From
Russia with another equally massive
dependence from anyone else we see that
energy Independence is the key for the
EU to become a respected geopolitical
player and that will never be achieved
by putting gas and nuclear at the heart
of our energy strategy as the president
said only Renewables and Energy
Efficiency can give us a strategic
autonomy we seek
it is not just for the climate that we
must accelerate the energy transition it
is for all security and for the
resilience of our economies the
colleagues
never before as the European Union be
challenged in such a direct and brutal
way
I have no doubt that we collectively
and only collectively have the strength
the resources the determination and
above all the wisdom to meet this
challenge together together with Ukraine
because we belong together thank you
thank you I give the floor
now to marcozani on behalf of the ID
group
[Applause]
president
thank you president president of the
European commission president of the
council
hi representative
the Cowardly attack
of the Russian regime is
showing Europe once again the ugliest
images of its history as was recalled by
President upon the lion
30 years since the war in the Balkans
once again in 2022
we're talking about a war in Europe
our support and
our extraordinary admiration goes to the
Ukrainian people
these people
who are tenaciously defending their
freedom and their sovereignty
when faced with them
unacceptable attack
it's great to see unanimous
criticism of the attack and it's great
to see that perhaps that for the first
time European Union institutions have
firmly and rapidly responded to an
emergency situation everyone's recalled
the sanctions package that has been
launched
and in terms of size length and impact
it is unequaled in European history
the approach and the unity with which
the European institutions have moved are
unprecedented
support for the Ukrainian people needs
to be total and we need to ensure that
we have
peace as soon as possible a piece which
restores the territorial Integrity of
Ukraine but at the same time as some of
you have recalled we also need to
look at the fact that the 24th of
February has changed our history there's
going to be a before the 24th of
February and then after the 24th of
February and we have to look at what our
errors and mistakes have been in the
past
what has led to us being unprepared for
a post February the 24th period Russia
isn't the only authoritarian regime that
is threatening the global order and
that's something we need to note
so let's try and look at these errors
that we've made
we've several times
mentioned
are dependents on Russia in terms of
energy gas oil raw materials
and they're also a market for our Goods
but this dependency was our political
choice we chose not to use our own
energy resources
and to buy them from Russia or elsewhere
instead
Europe is not a country what area excuse
me that is poor in energy resources
that's something we've chosen to be let
me give you an example in the 1990s in
Italy we were producing 20
billion cubic meters of gas a year today
we produce three not because gas in
Italy has run out but because we've
decided not to use it
and on sanctions
as we've said this package is
unprecedented but we have to be clear
it's going to have an impact on our
economy as well
and let me take up what our colleague Mr
Lambert has said
we've had two years of pandemic we've
had an unprecedented economic crisis and
we can't have the consequences of these
sanctions Weighing on our businesses and
on our citizens so I hope that the
commission will act quickly once again
to ensure that this doesn't happen to
ensure that our businesses and our
citizens receive the appropriate support
let me conclude just with a couple of
comments firstly
what we've seen happen with Russia needs
to be a lesson for the future there's
another non-liberal regime that's
threatening the west and that is China
let's not make the same mistakes with
China
that we made with Russia let's reduce
Europe's dependency on China that is
crucial
my second point
is more personal in nature and with this
I will conclude These are times of
History
in which
politicians are split between the Great
and the less great
in my country we say men and small men
and once again I note that unfortunately
at this time some people in this
Parliament wanted to see themselves
recalled
as small men they prevented my political
group from fully supporting the
resolution that we're going to be voting
on and this is something
that is a small gesture that that
doesn't damage my political group
doesn't damage others I think it damages
this institution which could have
assumed a unanimous position thank you
yeah
foreign
created an entirely new situation
and we have to do everything we can to
win this war because it's our war the
war of All European nations
once Putin decided to go ahead with the
invasion
it became clear
he is determined to subdue Ukraine and
will not hesitate to resort to the
Extreme Measures
it was he who once said let me remind
you that the collapse of the Soviet
Union have been the greatest
geopolitical tragedy of the century
so there should be no misunderstanding
as to his intentions
he plans to create what was once the
Soviet Empire perhaps not with one
stroke but that is definitely his final
objective moreover
uh he was he has been more or less open
about it all along
the Ukrainian Army
and the Ukrainian people are opposing
the Invaders
and they need they desperately need some
military backup arms and other tools of
Defense
fortunately after the initial
opposition from some countries some
nowadays it is about
20 governments I think that started
helping the ukrainians and it's very
good that some time ago in the council
the member states decided to create
European peace facility and that these
funds can be now used to help Ukraine
and I'm proud to say that it is my
government that was first to propose as
early as Thursday morning to activate
European peace facility so the flow of
arms the flow of Necessary Technology
and other means of Defense must continue
whatever the effects of the sanctions
who will win the war will be ultimately
decided on the battlefield
and and finally I must say this I'm
sorry I must say this because as usual
the EU is with its narcissistic and
self-congratulatory proclivities
likes to escape responsibility
Putin made his decision because he was
induced by the weakness of the West let
us be frank
he did not think much of the western
leaders and it showed he didn't hide it
and in a way he was right having been
for a long time tempered by the French
and German governments
by some adminary American
Administrations
also by the European commission that was
both unable and unwilling to stymie the
north stream projects
to those Western leaders and governments
that took upon themselves the job of
dealing with Russia
particular to the German politicians but
not only to them
we must say today ladies and gentlemen
you blew it
and your leadership credibility is gone
it's time for a reset let us start
and let us start by enabling Ukraine to
join the European Union
I give the floor next to mano Aubry on
behalf of the left group
madam
president president of the European
commission War has come back to Europe I
am part of the generation that was born
after the cold war that did not know
this clash of the big Powers I have been
told since childhood that Europe is
peace
however the ghosts of the past are
coming back to haunt us war is back and
let me say very clearly Vladimir Putin
is entirely responsible and today he has
blood on his hands
our group firmly condemns the
unacceptable military Russian aggression
against Ukraine and
would like to highlight the heroic
resistance of the ukrainians and their
presidents in the face of this invasion
the tanks are rolling in the bullets are
raining down terrified civilians are
trying to find shelter whether in the
underground or on the road to Exile and
it's those people I'd like to think of
first and foremost the ukrainians need
to know that we are not going to abandon
them
let me say to president zielinski that I
very much thank him for taking the time
today to speak to our Parliament
democracy and freedom those things that
his people are fighting for these are
our values too they are the antithesis
of Putin
we need to urgently send humanitarian
assistance without any conditions really
taking refugees without any distinctions
of the color of skins with no uh but
with no arguments the humanitarian
crisis is also geopolitical
Putin wants to take us into a world of
chaos and brutality where the strongest
prevail
and I say this very seriously colleagues
president vondeline president Michelle
we cannot accept
to become part of this terrible game and
for Europe to become a Battlefield
I warn you colleagues against becoming
involved in Military one-upmanship and
an arms race that would turn our
continent Into Fire and Blood as Genji
has rightly said you cannot wage war to
end War
the European Union must however defend
at any cost the only really valid
objective and that is peace and
de-escalation
strong and targeted sanctions have been
taken but for some of them how will they
be truly applied when there is still
impunity for tax Havens which hide the
wealth of Russian oligarchs
we need to tackle uh tax evasion and
criminality at an international level we
should be clear these economic sanctions
can only last so long the people will
feel the consequences through price
Rises that will have to be compensated
we all know that the only really
sustainable option is diplomacy all of
our efforts have to be focused on
obtaining a ceasefire and seeing the
withdrawal of Russian troops
the way to the path to peace is
difficult but it is the only reasonable
path we have NATO a military Alliance a
legacy of the Cold War is not the
solution NATO does not judge on world
peace that is the United Nations the
place to discuss the security of the
continent is not NATO it's the osce
the Ukrainian president has talked about
ways to move forward for example a
statute of neutality protected by the
United Nations we should support this
possibility I don't want to lie to the
citizens there is no Miracle Solution
but I do have a very firm conviction
what we need to do to counter Putin is
not to enter into a vicious cycle of
iPhone I a tooth for a tooth what we
need to see is the mobilization of
people for poor for peace in Russia at
rostov solid there was a young woman who
was imprisoned for uh eight days simply
for standing in the street with a
placard and that is a symbol for the
mobilization that Putin wants to try and
make invisible she symbolizes the
courage of thousands of Russians who are
defying the fierce repression of Putin
there are hundreds of thousands of
European uh who've taken the Ukrainian
flag and gone into the streets to call
for peace peace at any cost and let me
end with the words from Albert Camus on
the 8th of uh August 1945 just after the
bombing of Hiroshima looking at these
terrifying perspectives for Humanity
we see now that peace is the only fight
that is really worth fighting for
it is more than a prayer this is a call
from the people to their governments it
is a choice between how and between
reason thank you very much so on behalf
of the non-attached members to
kindergarten
president
Mr High representative
until last night more than 90 000
refugees arrived to Hungary this is the
biggest humanitarian program in Hungary
in history
and we are trying to help everybody who
wants to come to Hungary everybody is
welcome everybody will be helped
irrespective of which part of Ukraine
they're coming from and disrespective of
their ethnicity the entire country has
mobilized has been mobilized to help
them
the military aggression
you fully condemn the military
aggression against Ukraine
and we stand for the territory
territorial Integrity of Ukraine and the
sovereignty of Ukraine we are in favor
of United European action and we also
are in favor of Ukraine's candidate
status and despite all this information
we support all common suction sanctions
common decisions also the European peace
facility should be activated
we must not let ourselves be drawn into
this tragic War just on the other side
of the Border ethnic minorities are even
more vulnerable in war than in peace
times
we must pay attention to the security of
the ethnic Hungarian
community in transcarpathia we need calm
we need wisdom and we need the two
parties to engage in talks again we need
to restore peace in the neighborhood and
we must help Ukraine in any way we can
thank you
thank you for colleaguing
thank you very much now the next speaker
is Mrs China
Ukraine signed in their blood the EU
membership
I myself must apologize the ukrainians
and all others that I was too weak to
convince my friends in the West in time
that Putin is a major threat and then
the biggest provocation is not our NATO
or EU memberships but not being invited
enjoying NATO and the EU
but today there are no more Eastern or
Western Europeans
there is only our joint responsibility
for European continent
I want to turn to the Russians
you also can stop the war criminal Putin
I understand that you yourselves are
imprisoned and poisoned with life
but join us nonetheless
the ukrainians are dying for you also
for a free Russia
some human being in the Kremlin must act
too
to isolate this war criminal with a
nuclear button in his hands
those Maps
who went to the occupied Crimea
must now go to Putin and stop him
Ukrainian blood binds you
we are witnessing the beginning of an
end for Putin when that end will come I
cannot tell you
I only know that we must do all that is
in our power to bring it closer thank
you Ukraine Slava Ukrainian foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much
now Mr Pedro Marcus you have the floor
[Music]
thank you very much
vice president Madam president
and high representative
barbaric aggression against a free
country in Europe and of course we're
all United it reminds us of the Cold War
this war is not an illusion a people is
suffering yes for the Ukraine we have to
have
unprecedented unprecedented sanctions
against Russia and his oligarchs
we have to liberate Ukraine from Putin
and we also have to see that Putin
is trying to kill people if we don't
react today
then we won't have the possibility of
remaining United as a union we have to
work and express our solidarity and
maintain our autonomy in the world
and we have to
leave this crisis Unified
we have to do this for the children and
do this for the children of the Brave
and courageous ukrainians yeah colleague
thank you very much
Mr atrovich just is next
Mr chairman president High Commissioner
dear colleagues dear ukrainians
today we are back to 28 in the European
Union again
Ukraine has emerged as a great member of
the European family
Ukraine is Bravely
fighting for European values and freedom
for Europeans
let's give Ukraine its due
providing a candidate status now and
then accepting it in the European Union
every day that passes makes things worse
for Ukraine and we cannot allow it
today the future and the fate of Europe
is at this take in Ukraine
Russia's treacherous operation
only confirms
the Putin's regime's choice to draw new
red lines on the face of Europe
by ordering the attack on Ukraine the
Russian leader Putin has become a war
criminal and has brought the Belarusian
dictator lukashenka with him
they are already in the Dustbin of
History
their actions are already condemned and
soon be to be convicted
let us give Ukraine a weapon with which
it can defend itself against the
aggressor it's our duty
and let us provide humanitarian Aid to
its people who are suffering from the
crimes of its aggressor
this support must be such that the West
can look Ukraine in the eye
let us isolate Russia the full political
economic and cultural blockade keep
Russia down Kremlin chronis out and the
Russian people close Ukraine's Victory
is our victory
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
next speaker Mr circledinski
enia
we did not ask
for this confrontation
ukrainians did not ask for this
confrontation
ukrainians didn't spread hate
ukrainians didn't dream of Empires
ukrainians did not dictate their
neighbors What policies to follow and
which alliances to join ukrainians did
not occupy did not Annex and did not
blackmail
those actions came from Moscow
and my heart is bleeding when I say
those words
but ukrainians all they want is to live
a free life
in a free country
this is not much to ask
but this is a lot to defend
and this is why it is our European moral
imperative to help to help ukrainians
with refuge and money but yes also with
military equipment to help them defend
their own choice to help them save their
children their families their loved ones
the loved ones who take arms and walk to
battles help them to return
and yes this is why we have no other
options than to put a clear alternative
in front of President Putin either you
stop this war now or you will have to
bear the consequences that will be
devastating
we did not ask for this confrontation
you did
thank you
[Music]
foreign
next speaker
thank you very much vice president
Russia has to be hit by the hardest
sanction sanctions we have to send
weapons to Ukraine we have to send money
we have to send humanitarian Aid and we
have to receive those poor people who
are forced to flee Ukraine who are now
arriving in our home
we have to say no to Putin's regime and
we have to demonstrate that the
aggression that that Putin has
demonstrated towards a peaceful neighbor
is unacceptable that this action will we
will respond with serious consequences
and the kremlin's terror will never be
tolerated by the Free World The Free
World can only be on the side of Ukraine
I love Europe because of its diversity
and Ukraine is part of Europe the people
who are fluing fleeing from Ukraine they
are Europeans
and they are part of our European family
the ukrainians
are being attacked by Putin and so
therefore we should demonstrate our
friendship and help
dictatorship can never succeed and
Putin will never have enough right now
it's impacting Ukraine in the future it
could be affecting other European
countries we have to say stop
we have to stand up and we have to be
alert and ensure every country's right
to determine on its its own destiny we
have to be prepared to defend ourselves
against any Tyrant who will attack us
with Terror and War we need strength in
NATO and we need larger defense budgets
I support this resolution thank you very
much
[Music]
thank you
thank you very much after the cleaning
is Mr fitter
thank you president president of the
commission this is an unacceptable
tragedy
what's happening in our continent in
front of our eyes just a few kilometers
away from our borders there's an attack
being carried out from the Russian
Federation
on the territorial integrity and
sovereignty of a democratic country the
images that come from Ukraine show that
the attack is indiscriminate and
unacceptable but also sure show clear
violations of international law
we need to act to put an end to these
actions which are aimed at women and
children civilian populations this is
not war this is
barbaric and those who are responsible
need to be judged for their actions
these are barbaric actions against the
European uh the Ukrainian excuse me
people we salute their bravery and their
resilience
I think it's important today to
emphasize that the actions and role of
the countries on you
on Ukraine's western border
are crucial they're carrying out very
important humanitarian work
we need to work together with NATO and
other countries across the globe in
order to defend the values of freedom
and democracy and it's because of that
that the European Union and the West
who have made mistakes in the past need
to stand firm and together today
our group fully supports the sanctions
and any actions that will strike at
moscow's military
and economic power we want to see Moscow
forced to end this shameful conflict in
Ukraine we also need to be aware that in
preserving political Unity
we need to work hard to ensure that
public opinion is with us and
the people of Europe are going to suffer
given that this is coming on top of the
pandemic and economic crisis so we need
a fund to provide funds to citizens who
are struck by this by these sanctions
thank you okay
thank you very much the next speaker
is Mrs Villanueva police
thank you very much president
let me say that we firmly condemn The
Invasion by Putin and we want to show
maximum solidarity to the victims in
Ukraine in these very difficult times
it's also important to remember that
today there are extreme right groups in
this chamber who are allies of Putin and
who have helped to finance and work for
the destabilization of Europe and this
is not something we can continue to hide
Europe needs to act
firmly and with the objective of
building peace the priority has to be to
stem the loss of human lives this
conflict cannot be used to further other
interests we need to Foster spaces of
international dialogue we need to use
all the tools we have at our disposable
disposal to promote that dialogue we
know that that is the only way to end
this terrible tragedy let us not repeat
old
errors and see military
escalation which will lead to years of
pain this is the moment to be
involved in politics and show that
Europe is up to this challenge peace is
the only objective thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you for colleaguing
thank you much indeed now I'll give the
floor to Mr castaldo
thank you chair today we are not simply
condemning an industifiable aggression
today we stand up United in this house
to face the criminal invasion of an
authoritarian regime against
international law our principles our
values therefore against all of us
technical bat assumes it would quickly
overthrow the Ukrainian democracy with
his divisions on the ground but also
brings other divisions no less dangerous
through propaganda and fear within our
countries among our peoples our abundant
duty is to make sure that it will fail
with a Resolute support to the right
resistance in Ukraine and its official
recognition as new candidates and with
the immediate adoption of a new
solidarity package based on common
European bonds we must immediately
Support also our companies and families
who will suffer the dark consequences of
the dutiful sets of sanctions aimed at
bringing Moscow to the negotiating table
this is not the war of all the Russians
this is a crime perpetrated by a tyrant
and his accomplices thousands of
citizens are bravely taken to the
streets to shout their clear no risking
their lives to oppose his imperialistic
ravings they deserve our food supports
essential threat is a crucial moment in
our history and calls for exceptional
efforts if we really want to protect
peace democracy and our common Destiny
sometimes it takes courage to grow up
and become who we really are
thank you
very much indeed Mr Gala please
president
colleagues
what's happening is war in Europe in
real time
suffering innocent people is the biggest
catastrophe for
Ukraine since 1941 when Germany invaded
and the only responsible is a
cynical
lying dictator
who rejects the existence of Ukraine as
an independent state and wants to bring
his people back into the empire
this must fail
1948 beginning of the Berlin blockade
then Berlin mayor spoke to the world and
he said revisionist Russia is trying to
do the same thing now in Ukraine
to
to put your cranium people into their
guardianship
peoples of the world in America in
Europe in the Free World
look at that City look at that country
and understand that that country that
people
cannot be left behind
this people
and has said where it wants to be
we need to give that people a political
signal that they belong to us
that their Fight For Freedom isn't in
vain
that this evil this
stalinist fascist Putin regime will not
be victorious
and after
all of this is over they can start
reconstruction on a path to Europe so I
would ask for your approval of this
resolution
thank you thank you much Mr Gala
next we have Mr Piccola
thank you yes
the aggression of Russia against Ukraine
can be the beginning of the end of
humankind but it could could also be the
beginning of a new world order the main
reason for the war is the authoritarian
rule of Putin
which is worse
Putin's aggression or his narrative
justifying violence
Putin counted on Ukraine's passiveness
and the division of the west but he
overestimated his strength and
underestimated the Ukrainian resilience
and the ability of the West to come
together this will remind me of the
military aggression against my country
Croatia 30 years ago attacks on children
civilian buildings destruction and
refugees just as milosevic did Putin
must answer for his actions before the
international criminal court Putin will
find it difficult to come out of this
war
Kremlin might experience the Russian
version of the maiden history has shown
that dictators can be vanquished but it
is equally important to eliminate these
circumstances leading to their rule
Ukraine will bleed but Putin's Russia
will bleed out glory to Ukraine and
Slava ukraini
come
next we have Natalie luazu
again it took a war
it took her war on European soil for
Europe to learn to speak the language of
power
it took Vladimir Putin
and his War too far
for the transatlantic ties to re-tighten
for NATO to wake up and for European
Defense finally to emerge
but it took above all the extraordinary
courage of Vladimir zielinski and the
Ukrainian people for us
finally to feel obliged to try to rise
to the occasion
let's not fool ourselves the crisis will
be a long one and it will be tough
we will have to hold strong to pay the
price of our decisions
and above all to go further in
strengthening our Union
at the maidan in 2014 it was a European
flag that was flourished by the
ukrainians to call for the end of
moscow's Dominion
today in the shelters where they seek
Shelter From the bombs the European
flags can still be seen we are the ones
the ukrainians are looking to
we must prove to the ukrainians that
they are right to Believe in Us
we must love Europe
as much as they love it Slava ukraini
[Applause]
um
thank you very much indeed
vice president please
president
the attack on Ukraine has finally meant
that we have shown our unity in that
we've shown Global Leadership that's
what we've needed
I think we've been able to show that our
strength now has been brought to bear to
support Ukraine
silica The Finnish president said that
the mass now have fallen all we see now
is the face of War
what we see now
is
a very difficult development that we've
seen happening over many many years
we'll need to therefore work as the EU
as member states
and help our neighbors
we can't oh in Finland in a non-aligned
member state
we were
Frozen if you will but now we're
actually seeing
possible that we might be in the same
situation
countries that put themselves in
Russia's way this happens to them so
they we would learn how to look for NATO
colleague thank you much indeed Miss
pardella
thank you president
negotiations were underway more than
ever but available to me Putin took an
unacceptable step putting Europe under
the scourge of war the sovereignty of uh
people and country was violated so
solidarity with the people of Ukraine
they've entered into a resistance to
defend their Homeland but the tragic
lessons of History must not Cloud our
vision we need to look at the
complexities as we seek peace and
de-escalation
for 20 years now we've been moving in a
direction that has taken us under the
American flag and we have an imbalance
in our relationship with Russia
our own freedom to act has been
sacrificed to an illusion and an archaic
conflict
we need to be firm and we need to be
unambiguous in our unity and our support
for the people of Ukraine and our
condemnation of this Invasion it is
nonetheless dishonest for the EU
institutions to make use of this to take
a vision of federalism forward that the
people of Europe reject and NATO an
expansion of the EU won't help in any
way the priority is to stop
the arms Russia
should not
come back to
face a kind of sanctions which have not
helped undermining the purchasing power
of the people who already suffering
doesn't help with the Strategic autonomy
and the sanctions which have been in
place since 2014 have been in this case
we should not carry on using methods
which we can demo elsewhere
in Europe mature democracy such as uh
shouldn't be closing down media stations
even if they're under a foreign
influence it is also
no Fanning the Flames of War we need to
seek peace and de-escalation and we also
need to return to a free independent
respected France which is able to
operate in a balance in a multi-polar
world
[Applause]
our colleague
the president
I salute
heroism and and
resistance of Ukrainian people
facing the unprecedented aggression from
the Kremlin Putin's Russia Russian
Federation
uh I really admire heroism of Ukrainian
leadership President zelenski Oliver
defines his place in Universal history I
admire
heroism of commanders soldiers and in
particular Ordinary People you are
invincible
it is our war as well and in the in
resisting
aggression you are the best part of us
the West
we are honored
by your request to become a member of
the European Union will do our utmost
to provide you candidacy status as soon
as possible and immediately on
an unprecedented
rules the the membership therefore
because we need you and of course you
need us in this I speak on on behalf of
entire ECR polish delegation all of them
fully support the resolution as
negotiated by me thank you
thank you very much our next speak is
thank you president
we condemn the Russian invasion of
Ukraine no nuances
not eight years since dombas we've seen
impunity of the various assassinations
by these gangs of Nazis the men's
groomers haven't been
adhered to but nothing can justify this
attack we're against war and that's why
we cannot support this resolution
calling to arms and which refers which
says that it's a guarantee of peace and
refers to an instrument of War which is
NATO
and the sanctions that are against the
Civil population well never in the whole
history of uh conflicts as have
sanctions helped anything
a fund to support peace cannot be used
to buy weapons
we defend diplomacy politics is the only
way of resolving the conflict
we defend the ascending of humanitarian
Aid and opening the borders for those
refugees from that war
our Secretary General julangita said
May Wars be damned and the swines that
support them thank you
[Music]
is next please
our condemnation of the capitalist
aggression of Russia combines with the
condemnation of the war crimes of the
U.S NATO and the European Union against
the peoples of Yugoslavia Afghanistan
Iraq Syria and Libya the imperialist
competition for spheres and influence
and the natural resources led to the
capitalist War
which is paid with human lives and
poverty
all this 30 years after the capitalist
restoration of the Soviet Union that
socialism made it
for people to live in equity for decades
now armaments are paid by the people and
this leads to escalation of the
imperialist war with a deep intervention
of Greece through NATO bases
peoples do not choose sides no
intervention no involvement in the world
no
armies outside National borders
decoupling from the EU and NATO people
in power
thank you
thank you
billios
you have the floor
dear brothers and sisters in Ukraine
dear colleagues first of all I would
like to praise heroism of Ukrainian
people I would like to praise heroism of
Ukrainian soldiers and Zach heroic
leadership of President Vladimir
zielinski
ukrainians are facing and defending
themselves against the war launched by
real new Nazi regime in Kremlin Putin is
a real war criminal ukrainians are
suffering because we in the west till
now were too weak to stop putting crimes
from the very beginning
ukrainians with our blood are fighting
for their right to Rave night with
Europe they are more Europeans than many
of us that is why we need to give some
candidate status immediately and then we
need to design special fast procedure
for Cranium for Crane to join us there
is an example of such a special
procedure when in 1990 Eastern Germany
integrated into European union and it
took less than one year so let's
establish a special procedure also for
cranes Swift reunification with Europe
after you started to deliver weapons to
Crane when Swift and other banking
sanctions were introduced we need next
steps first of all we need to stop
Imports of Russian oil and gas
immediately each day we are paying to
put in for 100 new T70 72 tanks twice
more than ukrainians are able to destroy
during one day on the battlefield
second let's create multi-billion free
Ukraine fund to support resilience
reconstruction and modernization of
Ukrainian economy let's Finance it in
the same way as we Finance Next
Generation new fund we see you borrowing
Kinder markets thanks Jose Burrell for a
good idea said let's introduce
full-scale Swift and other sanctions
also against criminal lukashenko in his
Banks and the last Point stable peace on
European continent will be possible only
if the opportunization of Russia will
happen with the help of Ukrainian
Victors on the battlefields with our
sanctions and with the help of ordinary
Russians protesting on the streets the
opportunization of Russia is coming
closer and closer Mr Putin you lost this
criminal War International tribunal in
Hague is waiting for you for justice to
be served Justice first of all
ukrainians Rasam the perimorgan slavo
crane
foreign
[Applause]
mixer please
colleagues I am proud at how strong and
united we are today but we have to be
honest we have been painfully slow and
painfully late waking up to the true
nature of Putin's Russia
I hope that today we finally truly
understand the urgency and the
existential nature of the current
situation
if we do it is imperative that we
support Ukraine in every way possible
without holding anything back this
includes lethal defensive equipment
economic and humanitarian Aid help to
refugees and yes also launching the
honest and accession process for Ukraine
to join our Union
regarding sanctions in Russia
for as long as the criminal ideology of
putinism remains empowered in Russia we
have to go beyond punishing individuals
and take the Strategic decision of
systemically weakening Russia's economy
and Industrial base this is in our Vital
security interest yes sanctions he
taught in the Russians too and they are
not our enemies but let's admit it it is
primarily the responsibility of the
Russian people to make sure that their
matsar cannot kill Linus and people
abroad we should fully expect and when
possible encourage the Russian people to
take that responsibility seriously
slavocrine
foreign
next we have Malik azman
thank you president the courageous
Ukrainian people are standing up
to an evil Act of aggression
Europe answers Ukraine's call for help
who he writes up to defend those who are
fighting for freedom and democracy
to you is showing Unity
and we are finally showing that we are
not just a soft power
we are crippling Russia's economy
isolating Putin's regime and reinforcing
Ukraine's defense
but this is just the start and we have
to do more by excluding more Russian
operators and Banks from Swift
by blocking the Russian Central's bank's
use of Western currencies and we should
even consider blocking Russian ships in
our harbors and more
also we have to increase our support for
Ukraine's economy and defense with money
and weapons
my message to the Ukrainian people
Europe stands with you Slava ukrinia
thank you
thank you very much
Mr yanique Jadoo please
Mr President
colleagues at this very time in the
streets and in houses the ukrainians are
heroically defending freedom
they're defending their democracy their
territorial integrity
they are for Europe as a whole they're
doing this
for peace security and democracy on our
continent so yes
let's massively sanction Putin and the
oligarchs and immediately incorporate
Belarus into those sanctions yes of
course led us militarily support the
resistance in Ukraine yes let's
recognize the candidate status for the
European Union of Ukraine and
let's exclude Russia from the entire
International Community and launch a
major investment plan for climate and
energy security
to create
renewable energies at the heart of the
plan because they are the energy of
peace and let's get out of the political
complicity that is killing democracy and
killing the climate let's act now let's
be proud of Europe alongside the
resistance the heroic resistance of
Ukraine
Ukraine thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Mr urugu of the floor
dear direction of the European Union
colleagues before I will say a couple of
words about Ukraine I would like to ask
you a couple of unhonest questions where
were International sanctions when the
United States killed 200 000 civilians
in Iraq under the pretext of weapons of
mass destructions where were your
resolutions when the U.S completely
against the international law bombed
Yugoslavia Libya or Syria where was
Europe when a Ukrainian mercenaries were
killing children in donbas or were
burning civilians in Odessa I hope that
the actions of the last days are
teaching us that all wars are bad all
wars are bad not only the words of the
Russian Federation but also the wars of
the United States of America we have to
condemn all wars what's happening in
Ukraine is horrible and it has has to
stop it has to stop but the hypocrisy of
some of you calling leagues who ignore
Wars only because they are American
there's also hypocrisy it's terrible
um
is the next speaker
colleagues
the events we've seen
affecting all of the rules in such a
brutal fashion
against all rational thought
we've seen deliberate aggression brutal
aggression against a free Sovereign
European nation
and Vladimir Putin is the only one that
to be to be blamed
by doing that he underestimated what the
ukrainians could do he underestimated
how they felt about their independence
that's what all autocrats think he
underestimented the reactions from
Europe
your Korean Ukrainian resistance is
admirable and it needs our 100 support
we're very happy that Europe has taken
its responsibility to shoulder its
responsibility
but dissatisfaction working in unity
that shouldn't affect our Lucidity this
terrible war will last
the aggressor may actually win military
even though it has a lack of morality
let's not forget either that given there
is war in Europe
and we've had Wars since 1945 in Europe
we've seen already
that Europe believes that it's ready to
deal with these wars
since 1991 we saw a decade of terrible
wars in the Balkans
now we are moving to the Ukrainian
theater it is protecting more than
Justice States as an independent state
it's trying to we have to make sure that
we maintain our strategic Awakening
we have to deal with the situation that
others are imposing on us this is an
existential threat thank you Mercedes
here I think I mentioned indeed
next
Mr benefay
thank you president
there is no greatness where there is no
truth these are the words of Leo Tolstoy
as quoted by David cersoli a few months
ago addressing Putin and we need a truth
again today to achieve peace the truth
of the Ukrainian people who've shown
heroic resistance together with
president zielinski
the truth of Europe which is finally
fighting for its own political energy
and defense sovereignty and which is not
afraid to speak out and to make
sacrifices to speak with one voice to
stop war and save human lives because
victims come first Dead ukrainians Come
First the refugees we have to welcome
and those Brave Russians who are sick of
this military Folly also come first All
Peoples should be free including Ukraine
to make their own decisions make their
own choices
without others trying to take decisions
on their behalf so we give full support
today to the defense of our own
democracy on Ukrainian soil but we
should be even braver than that we
should be there our governments the EU
institutions should take delegations to
Kiev to talk to call for a ceasefire and
to support the negotiations Putin must
stop and then it will be all too clear
to his own citizens too that both he and
this inhuman War are mad lonely free
Ukraine Long Live Free Europe
yeah God thank you much Nick grazia
Mr getter please
[Music]
Mr Putin you have lost now of course you
will continue to kill and destroy and to
cause mourning and suffering but you
have already lost because you cannot
rebuild Empires believe a Frenchman and
that
absolutism uh will not last either
believe a Frenchman again now Ukraine is
resisting heroically and magnificently
and will do till its righteous victory
thank you
the union has tightened its ranks now
that now is taking the hopeful step to a
political union and you've brought the
two sides of the Atlantic together so
you've lost Mr Putin because your people
no longer believe you and will not
accept you going to Massacre the
Ukrainian cousins you're just a war
criminal Mr Putin you're also
an absolute menace to your very own
country that you have led into a corner
against its wishes Longleaf peace long
live Ukraine Long Live Freedom Mr Putin
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much
before Vietnam
before continuing the debate
I'm now going to give the results of the
first round of voting from
the day
uh
the understanding of that to the next
speakers so the results of the voting
round are as follows
on the amendment on Russia's aggression
against Ukraine
paragraph one adopted paragraph two
adopted paragraph three
Amendment four rejected
paragraph three accepted Amendment 5
accepted
22 23 24 rejected Amendment 7 adopted
29 part 1 adopted
29.2 rejected Amendment
29 part three
adopted
paragraph 15 part 1 and part two and
part three and part four adopted
Amendment eight adopted
paragraph 16.
amendments part one two three four and
five full
paragraph 17 adopted
after
paragraph 17 amendments 13 14 15 16 17.
adopted
15 16 and 17 rejected
paragraph 18 part one part two adopted
paragraph 19 amendment 9 rejected
19 Amendment 12 and 1925 adopted
on paragraph 19 Parts one two three four
five and six
they fall
paragraph 20 part one adopted
paragraph 20 part 2 adopted 21
amendments on part one two three four
adopted
paragraph 22 part one and part two
adopted
on 23 1 2 and 3 and Amendment
part three also adopted on 24 11 is
adopted on 24 part 1 and part two they
fall
25
adopted
27 adopted
paragraph 28 Parts one two three adopted
paragraph 29 Parts one and two adopted
paragraph 31 Amendment 26 is rejected on
31 part 1 and part two are adopted
34 Amendment 27 rejected
34 part 1 and part two
adopted 35 Parts one
two and three adopted
paragraph 36 amendments 19 and 18 are
rejected
after 37 Amendment 21 adopted
paragraph 39 adopted paragraph 40 Parts
1 and 2 adopted after 43 amendment 10
adopted after paragraph 44 Amendment 20.
rejected after paragraph 45
Amendment 28 adopted recital C part one
two three and four adopted after recital
d
Amendment one rejected
amendment 2 adopted after e amendment 3
rejected recital F part one and part two
adopted
recital G Parts 1 and 2 adopted
we shall now continue with our debate
and I'd like to ask our colleague
miraflav radakovsky to come up to the
lectem please
[Music]
dear colleagues I am the only Deputy
from the European of the European
Parliament that comes from Eastern
Slovakia my friends and relatives close
to Ukrainian border offer a great helper
to refugees running from the war and
they really condemned this war between
two Slavic Nations the Islamic
Parliament also condemns the unjustified
Russian invasion Ukraine and its calls
for immediate stop of this immigration
Slavic Republic has offered the Russian
uh and Ukrainian Representatives as
Bratislava for peace talks Islamic
Republic
does not agree with the new independent
countries so Slovakia does not also uh
improve the Kosovo status because this
was also with the help of foreign troops
I believe that in the near future there
will be
peace between two Slavic Brothers
Ukraine and Russia and we will do
everything to to be this way thank you
thank you and I now get the floor to our
colleague
foreign
ladies and gentlemen
children have been killed women have
been killed
towns have been destroyed
people there are fighting for us for
freedom for their freedom but also for
our values European values democracy
they're fighting for us for Polish
people for lithuanians for you ladies
and gentlemen in Western Europe
for all Europe to be able to enjoy
security they need weapons that's
obvious
but we can give them a lot more than
weapons
we can give them a guarantee
that once thanks to those weapons we've
they've re-conquered their freedom they
can live in peace in our family in this
European family and that should be
happening as soon as possible without
looking at the procedure we will find a
way of implementing that drive
dream but let's be careful as well let's
not make mistakes
if
if we want to suspend North stream 2 why
not suspend nor stream one
we need to cut the head off Mr Putin's
Mafia
we need to make sure they have no
Revenue they should be there in The
Hague International
Tribune for war crimes
and we should hand our put our hand out
today to everybody dreaming of Peace
that's the sort of view we want Europe
living United and in peace
and anybody against that is working for
Putin didn't start yesterday this war in
Ukraine in 2008 let me just remind you
Russia attacked Georgia and Moldova
transnistria
blood was shed then as well
so we have to be supporting those in
Russia who are fighting for peace for Mr
navalny
Long Live Free and Democratic Ukraine
thank you
Mr jenskaya you are the next one
[Music]
president thank you very much president
I'm grateful for this special sitting
because it provides an opportunity to
express
what the political message of the day
must be we condemn the breach of
international law committed by
Putin ordering the invasion of a
peaceful neighboring country and that's
the resolution that we tabled as the SPD
and we emphatically supported Schultz is
right this is Putin's war and we are
protesting against him not the Russian
people our thoughts are with those
people in Ukraine now who are fighting
for their freedom who are losing their
lives and who are fleeing to save their
lives Slaughter Ukraine the EU and its
institutions
in this
opportunity have shown that they can
rise to the occasion and there is an
unprecedented resolve that they have
demonstrated the EU foreign policy
therefore Works only when member states
want it the sanctions are hitting hard
many European
politicians warned uh Putin about how
costly an attack on Ukraine would prove
and that is being borne out now support
for the refugees who's continuing and we
are showing solidarity with the
countries on the Western border of
Ukraine who are providing the first
assistance they are not standing alone
our help for Ukraine and neighboring
countries require us to develop our
policies for further how do we create
Security in a multi-polar world that
question is one asked to us brutally by
President Putin we must find an answer
thank you colleague
and the next speaker is Mrs Hilda
Feldmans
High representative colleagues
Peter's got Putin has got what he wanted
more NATO more European Unity more
Western determination
and he really wants a dirty war Putin
against the west and now he's
threatening with nuclear weapons
everything is irrational
he's a warmonger
but let us not forget colleagues
autocrats throughout the world are
looking at what's happening how we are
going to protect our values how they're
looking at our reaction today and that
will decide which world we live in
tomorrow
24th of February the world changed
let's make sure that in this crisis we
see a new Europe born
a strong European Defense a strong
European Army to defend our values
where we work together we have a common
Asylum policy to be able to deal with
the refugees from Ukraine
a Europe
that is no longer dependent on Russia
for the supply of its fuel a Europe with
European solidarity fund for all
Europeans who are affected by Putin's
war that is the Europe that we need now
long live
Freedom Long Live Europe slavocrini
[Applause]
thank you and the next speaker is the
chairman of the foreign policy Committee
of this Parliament Mr David McAllister
Mr President thank you
the Russian military aggression and
Invasion against Ukraine is illegal it
is unprovoked it is unjustified
this is indeed a crucial and historical
moment
the Moment of Truth as commissioned
president Oslo Fonda line pointed out
too many times in the past the
International Community has been blind
in front of unfolding tragedies
today we as a European Parliament are
sending a strong and a United message to
the Kremlin that we stand with Ukraine
in full solidarity
a share of the Foreign Affairs committee
I would like to thank the colleagues
from the different political groups who
drafted and negotiated this resolution
and I call on colleagues to vote in
favor
I fully underline the very good
arguments we have heard today
I want to add one point
that is also strongly condemned the
involvement of Belarus in this
aggression against Ukraine
it was during last week's
inter-parliamentary conference on the
cfsp and csdp in Paris
made it very clear that the assault on
Ukraine wouldn't have been possible if
dictator lukashenka wouldn't have had
provided Russia the land and the
infrastructure the lukashenka regime has
assisted and enabled this Russian
aggression for this reason the EU should
apply further appropriate sanctions also
on Belarus dear colleagues the world
will hold Russia and Belarus accountable
for their actions thank you
[Applause]
thank you and now Mrs Kathleen Van Brunt
has the form
[Music]
thank you Sean
dear colleagues today we feel sadness
anger for sure but also Pride
pride in the unity of the European
response to Putin's war crimes
could you imagine just for one second
that we did not have the European union
today
then we would be divided and divided we
cannot have any response to Putin but
United as we stand today we have
Ukraine's back
Mr zelenski I know you have other things
to do but you know we have your back we
stand with you we stand with your people
in full solidarity in fight for peace
freedom and democracy and it is clear
Putin will only listen to clear messages
so we need to to use this clear language
so that therefore I think it's important
that we stop buying gas from Russia we
need to cut up from that gas
it's at the high price but it is doable
and if we do not pay the price today we
will be presented with the price
tomorrow and president zelenski was
right he said this is the crisis of
freedom and democracy well dear
colleagues in Europe let's take this
fight and stand up for our values thank
you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
a colleague thank you Mr Elan kuchuk
thank you dear president
dear colleagues we have a war in Europe
on a scale and of a type we told the one
to the history books
and let me be clear this is not
the war of Russian people
this is the Putin's War
Putin's regime is the one to blame for
walking the war killing civilians
destroying conscious infrastructure
Puri has attacked democratic values and
European aspirations of the people of
Ukraine
but the brave ukrainians stood up strong
and they deserve fully fed support
colleagues it's time to be on the right
side
of history and to Grant Ukraine
with candidate status
dear ukrainians
we will not you we will not let you go
I'm sure that the white will win over
the dark
we are with you the bright people of
Ukraine so our Ukraine
okay
you are our next speaker
and clear words so I will say four
things very clearly we can only live in
Safety and Security within the borders
of the 27 member states of the Union if
we are surrounded by countries which are
safe and stable in our neighborhood this
is why defending Ukraine means defending
the European Union we have to provide
all support that we can to Ukraine
including financial support and here
with the European Parliament have a big
role to play we say very clearly we are
ready to spend EU money to support
Ukraine and to rebuild Ukraine we are
ready to spend you money for defense we
are ready to spend more for democracy in
Ukraine and everywhere else where needed
as well secondly when people in Ukraine
say they want to join the European Union
our answer is yes you are welcome
Ukraine belongs to Europe Ukraine
belongs to the European Union this today
we say with the very large majority of
poor European members of the European
Parliament we know there is still a lot
to do until membership many different
difficulties to overcome but what proof
do we need more than what the people of
Ukraine are doing these days as a proof
that the people of Ukraine can overcome
all difficulties in view of becoming
member of the European Union one day we
start work on this as soon as possible
thirdly the Republic of Moldova a
country of Less Than 3 million people a
neighboring country of the European
Union has welcomed more than 70 000
refugees on their territory in the past
five days they provided food they
provided a shelter they provided support
they acted in European Spirit on the
basis of European values because they
are led by a poor European president and
the poor European government this is why
I say everything that we offer to
Ukraine we have to offer to the Republic
of Moldova right now in terms of EU
cooperation in terms of perspective for
membership the Republic of Moldova and
Ukraine are equally important for the
security of Europe and Lasting the
invasion of Ukraine and the assault upon
Kiev would not have been possible
without use this is why all political
measures that we apply upon Russia we
should apply in the same manner upon
Belarus thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much
thank you
Mr Robert beatron
[Music]
um
War has come back to Europe
and this is
a war between two worlds authoritarian
world and our world where you want peace
and democracy
it's a war perpetrated by Putin and the
heroes of the war are the ukrainians men
and women
it's not just about aggression against
Ukraine it's an aggression against the
whole of Europe all of our dreams of
peace and our peaceful Ambitions that's
why today we should remember that
Europe will never be at peace until
Ukraine is at peace Ukraine is part of
Europe
is that is this it's a moment of a hope
for millions of ukrainians
who are placing that hope in the EU we
should be opening our doors wide
for Ukraine before Putin closes his on
them forever I would ask every member
here every lover of democracy to show
their support for Ukraine they're
fighting for their freedom hours and
theirs slavocrini
foreign
the citizens of Ukraine have the courage
to stand up to one of the biggest armies
in the world and successfully so those
the courage to fight but also not to
give up on the values of Freedom which
are also the values of the European
Union this is a lesson for any
tyrannical and criminal regime that
wishes to abuse European aspirations and
value democracy and the freedom to
choose one's future with blood and
bombing but colleagues this lesson for
the citizens of Ukraine is also a lesson
for us those who have fought those who
have taken hold of freedom and peace in
recent decades our lesson is that we
must have the determination and courage
to open today the path to our Union to
all those Europeans who want to join in
this project who believe in it and fear
not just as they are standing up to a
great Army today so they will have the
strength to rebuild their country after
this disaster
the ukrainians deserve the EU opening
the door wide for them the same
applies to moldovans and Georgians the
commission has taken courageous historic
steps in recent days and this should
continue
united we are great power and this can
also be seen through the help given by
the citizens of Romania Poland Hungary
and Moldova and Slovakia to the refugees
from the war the countries that have
opened their borders for refugees
urgently need our support and that must
come Slava Ukraine
mates
thank you
uh
previous president and current chairman
of the Constitutional Affairs committee
Antonio
we are whole ukrainians
the whole of Europe the whole of the
West
we're on the side of freedom and
democracy
we will continue standing up against
Russian aggressors and stand up with the
strength of our own values
the cohesion and the resistance that
we've seen
from the Ukrainian people
and the strong role of Europe
of forced Russia to sit at the
negotiating table we all want peace
let us hope that the negotiations will
lead to attaining fundamental aims such
as peace but
peace cannot mean colonization of a free
country
many
citizens of Ukraine are fleeing War
and we need humanitarian corridors with
a refugee reception plan
we also need to take account of the
events of the last few days and respond
by having a true foreign policy and a
true common defense policy we need
Europe to be even stronger in order to
defend our values
we also need energy self-sufficiency we
need a single market for enemy if we
need a single market for energy if we're
really to avoid being held hostage by
any third party and we also need
solidarity we need to help families and
businesses
they've been mobilizing enthusiastically
in favor of sanctions and uh willing to
pay that price but we need to ensure
that we're helping those Brave business
people and families we need to help them
over the next few months and years
because it is true that
freedom and democracy do come at a price
the price of our commitment
but our commitment has no price we need
to help those who have fought with such
determination thank you
[Applause]
foreign
commissioner High representative
we've seen war in Europe bombs are
falling
civilians are dying children are crying
houses are collapsing
Britain's invasion
can only be described as
a an invasion in Cold Blood without any
regard for human suffering
the EU is more united than ever
and we're adopting the harshest
sanctions in the history of the EU
president zielinski
people of Ukraine must understand that
the EU stands with them we show
solidarity
Putin will see
that there is powerful tangible action
to stand up to him the EU is speaking
with one voice
once and for all and this aggression
against Ukraine must cease immediately
we must immediately step up to defend
Ukraine and to defend the EU the Swedish
flag has the same beautiful colors as
the flag of Ukraine and we stand with
the people of Ukraine
thank you madam president
we've all seen how the unjustified
unprovoked aggression by the Russian
Federation on Ukraine has caused a
humanitarian
disaster on a large scale as we speak
thousands and tens of thousands of women
and children and elderly people are
trying to save their lives crossing the
borders
these people are entitled to their lives
and civilized lives the right to
survival
people have mobilized governments uh
and citizens in Romania they're doing
what they can providing food and shelter
it's a tragic situation
and we've seen what
absolutely deplorable
conditions are experienced by these
people who've lost their homes for
example a woman who crossed the border
with a small child in their hands are
pregnant and had to leave their husband
home in their country and that's what
we're facing and
Ukraine Moldova should be candidate
countries these people deserve respect
and our support thank you I give the
floor next to Ms Tanya fayon for one
minute
foreign
thank you ladies and gentlemen I didn't
imagine I would ever stand here on this
stage and to stay stop the war in
Ukraine those who advocate for war
suppress Freedom the rule of law and
human rights must be stopped
nationalistic autocrats also in Europe
will be toppling democracies until we
stop them
and Russia's conduct is threatening the
post-war arrangements and security of
the entire Europe also exploiting the
war in Ukraine for political purposes
and profit is a disgrace only unity and
the Swift response of Western
democracies is giving us hope we
slovenians still carry Vivid and painful
memory of the bloody Balkan Wars and we
want peace
therefore there will be a large rally
rally in Slovenia today for peace
we have to help those affected by War I
thank everybody who selflessly
collecting and distributing aids to the
refugees and to all people in distress
not only today but always every war ends
at a negotiating table it's absurd that
therefore bloodbath destruction and
suffering ever happen in the first place
we should do everything in our power
that peace is achieved through the power
of international law and towards and not
due to the argument of force
for one minute
foreign
distinguished Madam president their
colleagues I will speak Latvian today
but being myself an ethnic Russian I
would like to try to address Russians in
Russia and in Europe as well
thank you much indeed
we see this war against
Ukrainian we see that Russia should be
ashamed
but Russians are protesting
and in Europe there are a lot of
protesters well
and a lot of Russian speakers in Europe
they are taking part in this process as
well
being Russian isn't a shame
but
but it's difficult to justify what's
happening you can't give
we need to do more in Europe we need to
give the EU the chance to become an EU
member as quickly as possible and now in
Russian
um
well we are against the Kremlin but
we're not against the Russian people
and it's important for us to say no to
this criminal war in Ukraine important
debate for this house I invite on behalf
of the commission vice president to take
the floor
foreign
[Music]
commissioner McGuinness honorable
members of the European Parliament but
first and foremost near ukrainians
shanovani Ukraine's
I have to say that I never seen a debate
in European Parliament
charged with so much emotions
solidarity and the sense of common
European belonging
as you know we come from different
countries from different political
families
but we are discussing today an attack
against the most fundamental European
values that we all share
and therefore today we are all
ukrainians
because the people of Ukraine are
fighting for our values
they're fighting for our freedom
and they are fighting for everything we
believe in for Europe as we know it for
Europe as we treasure it
and we will need the same Unity as we
felt this afternoon in this house in the
days weeks and months ahead
that Kremlin has failed
in its goal to crush Ukraine it felt to
break spirits of Brave ukrainians it
failed to divide or Scare Europe
on the contrary bravery and courage of
all ukrainians and calm and determine
leadership of President zelensk and his
government energize not only Ukraine and
ukrainians but the whole Europe all
democracies and I believe every
peace-loving human being in the world
Mr President zielinski
we have been working together to reform
Ukraine we have been working together on
energy Security on energy Independence
and we will be working together to build
strong Democratic Ukraine
Mr President
you ask us to do proof
that we are with you
and I would like to respond to you VR
we will make sure that the sanctions are
vigorously applied and not only on
Russia but also on Belarus
we will do our utmost to supply you with
everything you need
and we will be with you to rebuild your
beautiful country after your victory
nobody in Europe can doubt today
for the people that stand up so bravely
for our European values belongs in our
European family
and therefore I want to reassure you
that as we will come your women and
children in Poland Slovakia Hungary
Romania and other European countries
that in the same warm receptive way we
will open our arms to Ukraine in our
common house of Peace democracy and
prosperity called Europe slavo crane
[Music]
thank you very much vice president
and now on behalf of the council I
invite High representative Burrell to
take the floor
[Music]
you senior
president commissioner members
following this aggression
Ukraine Russia is reaching a crucial
juncture in its post-soviet existence
Russia
has
been to the end of an era in its
relations with the EU
the Minsk agreements
are now a thing of the past Putin has
done away with them
they were not perfect
they arose at a point in time when we
needed a ceasefire in a previous
conflict
nonetheless
those agreements
guaranteed Ukrainian territorial
integrity
and respect for those agreements which
is now inconceivable was something that
led us on a path towards a normalization
of diplomatic relations between Russia
and the EU
that is now inconceivable
and this is why I'm saying that Russia
has now reached a turning point in terms
of its post-soviet existence this
awful conflict
can only lead to a positive outcome of a
return of Russia to the fold of respect
for fundamental principles this is the
opportunity which we have in the EU we
need to seize this opportunity to put
forward mechanisms and treaties that
will ensure that there are mechanisms in
place for ensuring security so stronger
mechanisms in place that will allow us
to be very Vigilant about
their implementation
in the enthusiasm of a parliamentary
session
one can forget that the path of dialogue
the path of
speaking and listening to one another
is
at the heart of what we do in Europe we
should not forget that we are not a
military body we're not declaring war on
anyone we've actually
turned our back on War as a
solution as a way to resolve complex
what we're doing is standing alongside
a victim of an aggression
and we are mobilizing all of our
diplomatic resources in order to ensure
that we can Safeguard the security of
Europe but also
in order to find a solution to the
conflict
because they are unnecessary
and inevitable sanctions yes but above
and beyond that
we need Solutions
sanctions will hit and aren't indeed
already hitting the Russian economy
and Putin cannot claim ignorance of that
he had warnings President Van Der Lyon
the president of council
have said on numerous occasions cat
sanctions will impose a very high price
and that is now going to happen the
ruble has
lost 40 percent of its value
almost half of the currency reserves of
Russia
will be Beyond reach with a significant
impact on the economy there's a threat
of default
so taking a few Banks out of Swift
is Child's Play compared to this
because if you look at the figures
Russia had been preparing for some time
to face situations such as this and it
had been moving its dollar and Euro
reserves out into yuane into Yuan uh
remember and gold
so they're moving out of
dollars and Euros less than 40 percent
of their total reserves now
the 40 is still significant
135 million and gold but
even if there's billions in Gold who
who's going to buy it in order to sell
it you need a buyer
sanctions are going to prevent the
mobilization of these resources so these
Financial measures
are certainly unprecedented they'll
measures
will go from the direction of a
potential default
which will have consequences for the
whole financial system for the Global
Financial system so don't don't don't
value the importance of what we have
decided to do and what will follow
foreign
I want to stress that
and now we have to work diplomatically
all over the world
reaching out
all countries in order to build a state
of the Mind in order to aggressor being
condemned
and on that
I can assure you me as a representative
all my colleagues members of the foreign
Council all our delegations all our
embassies will be strongly working in
order to get a result on the vote on the
general assembly
this is the most important thing that we
have to do right now
because it repeats this is an issue
which belongs to the foreign security
policy which is intergovernmental and is
the member of State you have to take the
lead on these response and the
Diplomatic sphere
the second thing that has been
discussing today and this may be the
more important that many of us could
believe
visible dependency from the gas
president has been saying all the time
we have to reduce this dependency
but they've been listening for the last
20 years that we have to decrease this
dependency
and this dependencies has been
increasing during the last 20 years so
from now on
let's put where work in accordance with
our saying
because we pay
700 million dollars
for the world for gas and oil and gold
imports from Russia
and every year we import 200 billions of
matter meter could be met sorry cubic
meters of gas
have to increase Renewables president
said have renew hydrogen
but keep in mind
that the amount of power in a country
like Italy a year in Renewables
is less that half billion of meters
cubic meters so we have in front of us a
strong work to do
and we have to remain committed to it
and we have to explain to our people
what does it mean
this is a good occasion to develop the
best most novel side of the political
activity which is pedagogy
that's the moment to do pedagogy
and I understand the approach of a
parliamentarian chamber in a moment like
this I've been parliamentarian as you
many years even president of this house
and I know that this is the moment to
show and she has no support
but then we have to go to act
and next time when you discuss again the
budget of the European Union remember
that we need resources for to do what
today we are doing with an
intergovernmental fund that this
Parliament has never proved because it's
not
in the in your competencies
put more defense and security on your
mindset
stop discussing theology about strategic
autonomy
Khalid
the way you want
but we have to be more responsible
we have to take our responsibility more
in our hands
we have to be a strategically
responsible and this has nothing to do
against weakening the transatlantic
alliances which by the way has been
proven to be stronger than ever
and our united with the transatlantic
Partners has been 100
nothing against weakening NATO because
we develop our capacities
we have to become a hard power
I know that the words may afraid someone
but her power I insist is not just
talking about military
her power is having a power to coerce
the power to influence the decisions of
the others and what we are doing on
these measures
is a lot of hard power
be prepared for the answer
be prepared for the consequences
don't put all your strength in your
mouth
don't
say nice things only
from now on we have to be prepared to
resist
we have to be prepared to act in the
long term with a clear understanding of
which are our challenges and our
capacities
this is the moment for you to appear in
Union to discuss about what do we want
to be
what we are
which are the limits of what we can do
and what do we want to do in the future
in order to face the challenge of the
future there is a lot of things that we
have to review
a lot of things about our procedures our
other methods putting more attention
from our capacity to act
that in the time that we spend an
eternal discussions
what's happening today in Ukraine
remember me Buddha best
in 56.
I was nine years old but I remember
listening to the radio how the Russian
charts
were entering a Budapest
would remember me
88
the praga spring
it was enough in the Spanish Army then
and my unit was put into alert I don't
know why because it was completely
useless
on both cases we did nothing because we
couldn't do anything
but from now on we have to face a
confrontation between us
democracies people who believe on
freedom on multi-party system where
citizens choose their governments
when we live in a free market economy
trying to put together
economic efficiency and social cohesion
with the autocratic regimes
you just supporting themselves with a
click of people who take advantage of
the system while the great majority of
the people don't improve their living
conditions
all the war treasury that Putin is taken
from our gas payments
doesn't go to increase the well-being of
the Russian people
it goes to make more powerful is War
Machine
can pay for the gas everything which is
being spent on a Russian gas
and other goods are not helping the
people of Russia that's just going into
military expenditure by Russia and I
think very honestly that the time has
come for Europe to think of itself what
do we actually want for the future what
do we want to be in the future and I
think we want to be something more
than what we are now that is the true
challenge which we will have to face
over the next few weeks months and years
and that is why the conference on the
future of Europe can play a very
important role thank you very much thank
you very much hi representative that
concludes the debate the vote is already
open and will be open until quarter past
four and I now invite all the colleagues
that ask many people in the Esplanade
waiting for us to address them looking
forward to that thank you very much
foreign
okay